giannis congratulations on the win you
guys were down in this series 02
in fact one of those games you lost by
nearly 40 points
what does it say about this team that
you are now back to even says a lot
i'm really proud of this team we keep
playing together we come in every night
and putting ourselves in the position to
win
uh you know uh live in brooklyn we know
that the
the two kids of our business so we say
we're going to go back to work we won't
try to take care of business and we put
ourselves in a position to win two games
we're very happy but we gotta keep
getting better
keep playing together hopefully we can
go in brooklyn and uh take one
this was such a physical game and of
course the nets lost one of their big
stars kyrie irving
he twisted his ankle landing on your
foot what happened
on that play from your perspective uh i
really don't know i thought i thought he
got hit in the groin at first
when i went back to the locker room they
said that he uh
explained his ankle i wish him quick
recovery hopefully he can be
ready for game five wish him nothing the
best
but we got to keep focusing on ourselves
keep focusing on the task keep having
fun and uh
try to win games you guys did so much
work this season to get to this moment
including
changing some of your personnel pj
tucker one of the guys you brought in
this season what impact did he have on
this game today he
keep playing hard keeps makes everything
tough for kd
he's vocal he's a leader he pushes us to
be great
uh he's a definitely big piece of uh
this organization this team
and uh he's gonna keep helping us and uh
we definitely moving forward what are
your main keys for going to brooklyn for
this next game focusing ourselves
focus on the test which is try to get
one from brooklyn
and have fun just have fun and hopefully
we can
be in a position to win the game have
fun is one of the best answers you can
give congrats on the win giannis we'll
see you
over in new york thank you back to you
mike